joining us now is cbs news chief
washington correspondent major garrett
major good morning to you
let's stay with that news about troop
drawdowns in iraq and afghanistan long
and costly wars there the president has
said he wants to end them
now it seems he's trying to but why now
because he's only got two months left
well if you're
asking yourself why hasn't the president
conceded because he doesn't want to but
are you
asking yourself is he taking moves that
suggest that he knows
his time in the white house is coming to
an end yes and this would be one of them
the president has been driving his
civilian and military leadership in the
pentagon
toward this for quite some time but he's
accelerated that push
it's been clear from the reporting of
david martin our colleague at the
pentagon
that the military advisors knew this was
coming and wanted to put it in
to practice as best as they could and
shape the president's initiative
as best they could they've done that so
the president hasn't conceded he hasn't
acknowledged the result of this election
which are fundamentally clear
but yet he's taking moves that suggest
he knows his time in the oval office is
limited
shifting troop levels in the middle east
could have an impact on intelligence
briefings
president-elect joe biden is not getting
those briefings how significant is that
it's more significant as time goes on in
the first couple of weeks you could
probably have some slack in the line and
not really be
that far behind but the longer this goes
the
more incremental the damage increases
and for the incoming president-elect his
team wants to sit down
with the existing administration at
least hear their thoughts
and get their latest read from those in
the region
friend and foe the longer they are
deprived of that
the more difficult their ability to as
they like to say hit the ground running
will be
now to the president's legal battle here
in the u.s yesterday in pennsylvania
the president's lawyer rudy giuliani had
to acknowledge in court that they're not
even bringing a fraud case there and yet
these baseless cases continue there and
elsewhere
what's behind the president's strategy
and any cracking in the unified front
that republicans seem to be presenting
there are cracks and you saw them on the
floor of the senate yesterday
there is no strategy tony there is only
anger and resentment about an election
result that republicans in the trump
campaign wish
turned out differently guess what that
happens in american politics you can
lose an election narrowly
there is no coherent legal approach to
challenging any votes
in any jurisdiction not one single vote
has been brought into legal question by
any of the litigation brought
by the trump campaign or sympathetic
republicans and in court you have to
meet two standards
a point of law and evidence to back up
that it was violated so far
zero on any either of those fronts yeah
important point there not a single
vote so far has been invalidated or
called into question
with evidence correct lots have been
called into question without evidence
correct important distinction major
garrett forest thank you very much